Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David P here is
kind of like a which would you rather
and I I'm I'm aware that this voicemail
may be asked in bad faith of me. I don't know
for sure, but I don't care. I think it's an
interesting question and I have a very clear
answer. So let's take a listen. If you want to
leave a voicemail to one nine two David, P..
Speaker 6: Hey, David. I have a hypothetical
question for you. Would you rather step onto
an elevator with someone who is unvaccinated
or would you rather step onto an elevator
with someone who is smoking a cigaret? That's
just a hypothetical question.
Speaker 1: Yeah. No. I mean,
it's a very I would rather step into an
elevator with someone who is unvaccinated rather
than with someone mandating cigaret smoke
like a chimney. If I wear a mask around
someone who is smoking a cigaret in an enclosed
place. I think that that smoke gets through
just about every mask. People could correct me
if I'm wrong. I think I think even with an N95,
cigaret smoke particles are smaller than COVID.
Also, if someone is unvaccinated on an elevator
with me, it doesn't mean that they are sick.
Statistically, they're not sick. So it seems like
a very easy question to answer. And, you know,
sometimes with these questions, again, the reason
it's sort of a weird question. Maybe it's just a
curiosity. You know, the answer is obvious to me,
but sometimes people try to use these
questions as sort of gotcha. Like, if I say no,
I'd rather be in the elevator for four 20 seconds
or whatever it is with someone not vaccinated,
rather than with someone emanating cigaret smoke.
You know, there's no there's no vaccine against
conditions caused by cigaret smoke. I mean, it
just doesn't make any sense. It's like the answer
is irrelevant to anything about vaccine
or mask policy. And that's why I wonder,
oh, sort of like what the point of the question
is. But if you disagree, if there's let me put
it this way, if there is anyone in my audience
who would rather spend 20 or 30 seconds in an
elevator with someone smoking cigarets rather than
with an unvaccinated person masked or unmasked,
whatever doesn't doesn't matter. For me, the
answer would always be I'd rather it be with
the unvaccinated person. It's a short amount of
time I can wear a mask. I have three vaccines, so
that that would be my answer. We are going to have
a big story tomorrow about what's happening with
Russia and Ukraine, and the situation does seem
to be escalating there significantly. One of the
elements of that is that the U.S. State Department
has ordered the families of embassy staff in the
U.S. Embassy in Ukraine to leave the country,
and we're going to talk about that on today's
bonus show. We also are going to talk about New
York City, New New York City Mayor Eric Adams,
who has taken, I don't remember if it's his
whole salary or his first payment in bitcoin
that has now been devalued significantly because
of the decline in cryptocurrency markets. So
we'll talk about Eric Adams. I think there are
some NFL players or at least one being paid in
bitcoin. We're going to talk about it. I'll also
talk about what I have done. If anything, with my
bitcoin hint, I've done nothing. That's almost
always my strategy. And thirdly, the Arizona
Democratic Party has formally censured Kirsten
Cinema, and we are going to talk about like, what
does that mean? Does that really do anything? What
are the impacts of that and what is it that does
it? Does it really have any repercussions for her
at all? So that's all going on. I hope you will
join me this Saturday evening. The next Donald
Trump rally for the 2022 campaign season will be
taking place in Conroe, Texas. And as I mentioned
earlier, if you live nearby and you can get there,
we want to hire someone in the audience to go to
the rally. Interview people live with me on on via
Skype or Zoom will figure out how to do it during
our live stream. So get in touch info at David
Pakman dot com. Let me know what equipment
you have and the equipment might just be like,
you know, an iPhone and a microphone. You
plug into it your ability to get there.
If you know how you can get yourself in ET we're
we have we're going to hire one person to do this.
But get in touch info at David Pakman dot com. We
have a fantastic week of shows coming up for you.
And remember that you can get instant access to
the bonus show by signing up at Joint Patricof.